video games okay the playstation 4 slim
sometimes we all just need to you know
trim little bit uh yeah who's that who's
that underboob who's that a little bit
of a baby fat they just never got rid of
hey got your lump asst you know you're
like it's a compass that's not real
we're like bags up that's operating
anyway okay so Sony you know had a bit
of a heavy early years that have decided
along this if you yes decided to slim up
a bit and thanks to the good people at
gumtree which I did you guys ever heard
of gum tree before any of this think
it's like a weird hybrid of like
Craigslist meet ebay yes like
unprotected auctions it's basically the
craigslist objectives like when I found
like in the night you don't wear
protection when you meet people on come
yeah and it's a it's like when I moved
to London gumtree was where I found my
flat sure I'm like when I want to join a
soccer team gum trees work my team like
it's basically craigslist and now it's
where you reveal unannounced hard way
yes apparently yeah there was an ad on
gumtree which a couple of outlets picked
up push square I think one of the first
then it was a gas right out of it and
then your gamer basically wrote about it
because one of the folks from digital
foundry went to the person and like
straight up shot a video of this I just
to make sure wasn't 3d printed I guess
because that's the new thing that people
do there was that elaborate Wii U or in
Nintendo NX hoax Wes like really well
done I thought like that fooled a lot of
people and they and they came out later
was like no no we faked all of this none
of this was real in him I'm weirded like
a marketing company or they were like
some they were like industrial design
company they actually like showed how
they the process they would data create
amazing add this one it does a video of
it out there booting up in fact your
gamer actually subsequently pulled the
video because of legal concerns and
which is interesting I've legal concerns
being we want Sony to continue working
with us please right yeah which kind of
in its own way confirms it then yeah
that that's like that's what it looks
like so i guess initial thoughts what do
you think Peter what do you think how it
looks I think it looks good it kind of
like the the first redesign of the
playstation 3 that when they the
original slim yeah it looks kind of
benign you know there's like nothing
really like like I catching about it
but that's okay I'm sort of of the mind
that you don't need to have your systems
and this like huge display right
scenario um but what I'm really excited
about is the idea that this will be
using processors built on a smaller
manufacturing process which means
they're going to be cooler and quieter
okay that sounds rad to me my
playstation 4 isn't as loud as an xbox
one can be but it's still loud it's late
enough and it can intrude on just mine
like I don't want to hear that right so
I'm happy for that reason alone it will
probably be cheaper and it just looks
like it looking more spelt package I
don't think we're gonna see I don't
think there's any like hardware
improvements beyond the size and
efficiency of the stuff this is the 4k
stuff or any of that stuff that we know
from neo like nobody's saying that
that's gonna get old / yeah founded you
mean unless there's something in like
the manual that this guy has that
references like maybe the sort of hdmi
cable you need to attain for kids right
right like maybe there's a reference in
there but without that reference I don't
think that's even remotely possible
right I really love the design because
it's like two things sandwich together
and I just want to paint the inside of
it white so to be like a big ice cream
sandwich okay that is it that's all okay
can we talk about that further than
actually like the whole trends towards
know the whole sort of trends towards
like very minimal like what was it you
said like low impression i get like
consoles that dont stand out cuz like
that was a thing for a while would like
you know and mary was talking about had
this kind of looks a bit like an apple
TV which is like in pisa harder which
has almost been designed so you couldn't
see it writes just to sit by a
television I mean like we think about
like the original xbox or like even the
PlayStation 2 when it's grayling the
blue aspect to it and the xbox 360 even
this big crazy white looking thing with
a big logo that lights up when you turn
it on gamecube you get rice like it kind
of sucks right they look this way mad
like I get it like but also like I get
it like I'm 30 but if I was like a
teenager again I'd want this it's like
when I was used to mod my pc cases like
I liked weird-ass looking shiny colorful
stuff you know it was like a safe middle
road like if you look at the Super
Nintendo that you got and that Japan got
right not the one that us got but the
one that you guys got was very clean and
had certain accents that gave it
character without being ostentatious
right when you look at so many consoles
like take
p.s to the original and you throw it on
the stand the vertical stand right it
was just like turquoise gradient thing
this is gross like in my opinion it
doesn't look great like sure yes a
teenage kid might like it to a degree
but as an adult now like I not only
don't want to look like a child when I'm
gaming because I don't think it's a
childish pursuit and doesn't have to be
portrayed that way yeah but I want
something that's respectable looking
like in terms of design like you can
recognize clean design in something like
the PlayStation 4 as it is right now
right maybe less so with this because
it's taking fewer risks but I don't
think that's necessarily a bad thing I
mean even the original PlayStation I
think is you know a rectangle three
circles yeah very simple and clean but
it still was able to communicate that
this is a gaming device without looking
garish yeah that's in people are they're
not gaming devices they are
entertainment device sure right for so
much right that's that's what the trying
to pitch anyway right it's not just for
the kids who play call of duty this is
for everyone who has any interest in
gaming entertain or entertain ya like
you know watching movies are streaming
that whatever yeah so I guess um is it
interesting at all that there's no
bundle around us it seemed like that we
don't know have this individual acquired
us but the box that they had was like a
clean this is in console whenever when I
was working in gamestop and stuff like
whenever a new console came out it
always seemed to be bundled with
something like as a sort of thing but
got a couple of these out there kind of
thing I feel like not putting it on the
box gives you more freedom like it gives
you more it gives retailers freedom to
bundle make their own bundles or
regional so you can just have the same
basic box everywhere and then just like
n this is this week we're gonna come
with this game which is really annoying
because this could be for a lot of
people who want to maybe get a new ps4
who already had one and it sort of run
its course and they just want something
smaller and more efficient Oh whose ps4
has run its course it's a little early
for that I don't know anyones re i don't
know i just throw that out there I'm
done with this ps4 I I mean my ps4 is
really loud for instance right and
that's that's probably because there's a
lot of dust kicked up in there like it
wasn't allowed to begin with cat hair
sure yeah it's like Connor um but yeah I
know I think you clean it every now and
then just take a duster togi a dead dog
snake in there as well uh yeah no I mean
I don't think the bundle thing is that
strange I think he makes a good point
and they're probably also trying to come
in as low as a price point as possible
so to allow that flexibility for
retailers and themselves to at least
make that
offer they could be 250 with this thing
right yeah that would be crazy I mean it
is i guess in one way it is going up
against xbox xbox slim slim mess
whatever they am apparently expected to
debut this on September seventh when we
think we're going to see this in
retailers on I think immediately like I
special especially now it's literally so
I think this was just jumping the gun of
and we announced it and it's available
now in stores which is a really hard
thing to pull off these days because
it's the Internet yeah not totally not
surprised that this happened that at UK
like I'm sure I've talked about it
before when I lived in London there were
like I had a game store that if you paid
to my extra fiber they still a G game
before I came out and I was like 2013 or
twice Wow just nuts you know you just go
in on a Tuesday after I'd like played
football this place and I'd walk in and
he was like yeah we got a fiery a
pre-order you know we got her tick
wasn't there couple stories the past few
years about like shipment trucks with
games go yeah getting robbed and jacket
yeah yeah and all that stuff probably
goes up on gumtree and softened you
can't hide it anymore it's not like you
know back when we were kids where maybe
somebody could talk about it and like
now you can just start streaming that
gameplay yeah immediately right away I
wonder if maybe the US has more chain
stores as well than the UK does because
like gamestop does exist there and game
exists there and like virgin and stuff
but there's a lot of like single owned
independent game store still here until
just go we just don't right now the rest
of the country is better okay really
yeah it is it is alright anyway I'd say
it ps4 slim leaked it's out there
spilling all over the place you think
gonna buy one let us know in the
comments below
you